décisions importantes ce jour-là à
l'espace jeunes anatole-france de la
ville de trappes
le choix du nom de leur émission de
radio ce sera donc trappe radio au
programme une interview du maire adjoint
à la jeunesse et aux sports à l'aide
d'un micro trottoir réalisé la veille
l'intérêt c'est vraiment de leur dire
comment on pourra intéresser un auditeur
et après ils ont un petit peu le champ
libre pour faire ce qu'ils veulent là
dessus et des chroniques sur les thèmes
de leur choix qu'ils préparent
minutieusement un fait les recherches et
après et après un des personnes qui
écrit les personnes qui cherchent on
s'est dit avec tout ce qui en ce moment
et tout ce qui se passe à la télé tout
ce qui se passe et tout leur faire
découvrir ne pas rester juste sûr on
voit ce qui se passe à la télé on reste
bloqué sur ces images là leur dire
maintenant mais il ya autre chose et de
la préparation derrière il ya des
recherches d'un faux
neuf jeunes âgés de 13 à 16 ans
participent à cet atelier découverte des
médias derniers tests sont comme des
pros avant la grande interview pour
laquelle ils ont choisi leur thème
l'évolution numérique et l'égalité
femmes hommes
j'ai une deuxième question qui me tient
à coeur c'est qu'est-ce qui est mis en
place à trappes pour lutter contre
l'inégalité homme-femme des thématiques
qu'ils explorent ensuite en chronique
critique de livres d'horreur éléments
d'information sur un duo de rap français
réflexion sur ce que l'on peut faire
avec 500 euros et même des billets
engagé j'espère aussi que dans quelques
temps il y aura plus de femmes qui
auront des métiers plus important est
qu'ils ont qui aura une femme présidente
je pense que c'est là son réalisera au
fil du temps attention messieurs les
amarres pourquoi ce thème parce qu'il me
tient à coeur je trouve ça
important d'en parler j'ai parlé du
salaire des hommes et des femmes j'ai
parlé de ce que ce qui pourrait le faire
pour changer cela
les voix des jeunes sont posés radio
trap est dans la boîte